Quindi il concetto di fondamentalista è essenzialmente legato al
concetto di misurazione nella meccanica quantistica
prima che la meccanica dei punti venisse sviluppata
era in genere una conoscenza
degli scienziati che se hai un sistema che
si trova in un determinato stato
ed esegui una misura su di esso otterrai
un risultato ben definito, voglio dire un esito
nella meccanica quantistica non è più così, puoi avere
un sistema che si trova in uno stato perfettamente ben definito
eppure quando esegui certe
misurazioni su di esso puoi ottenere esiti casuali
quindi per illustrare meglio questo concetto
ho bisogno di introdurre il concetto di sovrapposizione
la sovrapposizione è un concetto che non è qui liquido
si basa su un sistema che mostra
diverse combinazioni lineari di stati
simultaneamente e puoi pensarci
ad esempio come un'onda radio che porta
molte frequenze diverse, non c'è nulla
di umanamente incomprensibile in questo
ciò che conferisce il sapore quantistico alla sovrapposizione è il fatto
di misurare il sistema
quindi lo illustrerò con un esempio
immagina di avere un sistema di frecce
e di preparare il sistema
in modo che tutte le frecce puntino a sinistra
e poi vai e
fai la domanda: sei su o giù?
e ogni freccia, poiché le frecce puntano a sinistra, può essere
espressa e descritta
come combinazione lineare della sovrapposizione tra
su e giù, otterrai
come risultato cinquanta percento su
e cinquanta percento quando fai la domanda sei su?
ottieni quel risultato dal sistema
e poi puoi preparare con quello
uno stato diverso del sistema dove metà
punta in su e metà punta
in giù e fai la stessa domanda
e ottieni lo stesso risultato
sono due sistemi molto diversi
eppure hai ottenuto questa informazione
per molto tempo ora
come puoi determinare qual è la differenza?
i cittadini sono molto diversi
perché nel primo caso hai preparato il sistema in
uno stato puro, in tale stato occidentale puoi
chiedere al sistema qualcosa che ti darà una risposta deterministica
non casuale, e quella domanda è sei a sinistra o a destra?
ti dirà al cento percento che è a sinistra
nel secondo caso non c'è domanda che puoi fare
che ti dia una risposta al cento percento deterministica
perché è una miscela
quindi se chiedi sinistra o destra
sarà casuale perché metà sono su
e metà sono giù, se chiedi su o giù
stessa cosa, sarà cinquanta percento
come si collega questo alla casualità quantistica?
puoi immaginarlo
simile al lancio di una moneta, sarà testa o croce
ma non è come lanciare una moneta per niente
perché quando lanci la moneta
l'unico motivo per cui non conosci il risultato che otterrai
è perché non conosci
l'energia con cui hai lanciato quella moneta, l'angolo di momento e
le condizioni ambientali nella stanza
e così via, quindi se conoscessi tutte quelle
variabili potresti prevedere testa o croce, sono
variabili che sono nascoste all'osservatore
e per molti anni gli scienziati pensarono che ci fossero
variabili simili nella meccanica quantistica che si sarebbero
rivelate come casualità
e non fu fino al
seminale lavoro di John Bell negli anni sessanta che fu dimostrato
che non è così
e ora ogni fisico
riconosce che non esiste alcuna teoria
delle variabili nascoste compatibile con la meccanica quantistica
quindi è davvero vero che quando misuri un sistema
la natura rivela il risultato da
non importa quanto a lungo ci pensi, e io
rispondo che è straordinario